i did a very long chat with david um
prior to that q a that we did and he
mentioned something to me that i hadn't
that i didn't know which is you guys
have actually talked about doing like a
live action
or this is what he said that you've
talked about doing the live action love
death and robots um and i'm sort of
curious is that something that like
that's real is that something that was
really really talked about or is it more
like david just teasing it
well there was a live action yeah
you mean like a series like a
live-action anthology exactly
uh cool actually
it would it would be cool
um
no i ca i don't i don't know what he i
don't know what he meant steve i think
he was just [ __ ] with you
yeah we have we have we do feel like
obviously there's a focus on animation
and there and there's an animated
component to all of these things but it
doesn't mean that we couldn't under the
shiny chrome love death and robots logo
do
some do something in the live action um
world
one of the many things i love about the
series is that um each episode you don't
know what it's going to look like or
feel like until you push play and so can
you sort of talk a little bit about um
how you guys decide what animation style
will be used in the storytelling
sometimes it doesn't come out until we
meet the director and their particular
pitch because sometimes you're leaning
into whatever that director's
specialization is like
in some cases so
we will try and find the director or
studio that specializes in that thing
for instance something like a
stop-motion piece you're only going to
be talking to certain studios because
that's what they do
um but really for us it comes down to
the story what does that story want what
what director is passionate about that
story what does that director do
i i think there's very little though you
gotta admit
we kind of feel it right even when the
story is like i feel like this one's
gonna be 2d or i feel like this one's
you know like all through the house no
question but that was going to be stop
motion when when that came in because it
reminded us of all those childhood
memories of you know rudolph the red
nosed reindeer and all those ranking
bass
stop motion pieces but um
there was no question that yours was
going to be stylized in 3d there was no
question that
finchers was going to be um high-end 3d
so i feel like there's a
there's a leaning that can some
sometimes get twisted ice um from last
season was one where
i didn't
originally think 2d for that one and
then it became
um that when when robert valley became
involved so the draw giant could have
been live action and then became
animations actually it was going to be
live action at some point i've talked
about this before but um you really
don't know how each episode is going to
end until you're actually watching it
you know because some and some end in
moments i'm like oh i want more you know
like in fact that's most of the episodes
and uh so i'm just curious can you talk
a little bit about how you guys all
decide on where something will end and
how many have gone through radical
changes in terms of where that end will
be well those stories are short stories
most of them so
nearly all of them so we do follow close
to what the story was in a couple of
cases ending has changed pop squad's
ending changed
isis ending change but it really comes
down to when you translate it to visual
medium what is a satisfying ending
what's going to be
interesting for the viewer to experience
that may be different from a story
written yeah and sometimes we are
thinking like
what status because you know we're in
the entertainment business and we want
people to be entertained ice is a good
example where the ending uh the original
story was kind of down and the brothers
didn't like each other and it didn't
heal any of their wounds and they were
as dysfunctional as they were when the
story began but i didn't want people
walking out feeling
badly about that likewise pop squad
nobody should get away with murdering
children
there has to be a price my sense of
justice just didn't feel satisfied um
and so
you know he had to die through the magic
of scripting
yeah he had he had to die um i believe
tim you said uh um previously one of my
favorites is snow in the desert and you
mentioned i believe that that went
through some pretty big changes between
you know the story i'm not exactly sure
what happened so i'm i've been waiting
to ask you how exactly did snow in the
desert change was it originally a lot
longer uh what can you say it was like a
50-page short story yeah it was a it was
a long one yeah that
i wouldn't say that
tonally it changed or even or even the
ending really um
it it just had a lot more stuff right
it's set in neil asher's larger universe
so there's a lot of
political [ __ ] there's a lot of talk
about other planets and how everybody is
involved um and why they wanted snow and
what it would mean to the general you
know galactic
political system if eternal life was
there and we hinted that in the story
but it was really hard to like cut out
all that stuff
um without
without making it feel like sort of a
bare bones um
structure for a story and just hint at
this larger world without really
going into it it's a funny thing with
stories where you can walk that line
where you
are are
making people feel satisfied but not you
know going into tons of exposition but
it's just enough color to make it feel
like there's a vibrant world just off
screen you know one thing that's useful
is there are compilations of the short
stories if people are curious they can
read what the original story was and
then see how it's been adapted into
the shorts themselves and it's very
educational i think to see what was left
out what was it sort of elaborated on
and those compilations are yes it's
coming out soon and funnily enough the
snow in the desert was the hardest one
that we had uh trouble with getting the
rights and by the way all the money goes
to the authors and to the publishers
it's not to netflix or us for these
compilations because i wanted
this the real short stories
but
but that one in particular i'm like
there's a whole ton of [ __ ] in this
story that is really interesting but we
just couldn't put in 15 minutes and
now people can read it
at the beginning of every episode you
have those symbols they constantly
change um who gets to decide what those
symbols are going to be
jen miller
yeah our ep and my m and my wife
jennifer miller she kind of comes up
with those with
an artist named jared perrington and
then they kind of pitch us um all these
different symbols like uh the penis in
the circus tent that is
at the end of the brown giant but
they're like little haikus little long
lines of the
story
most of the episodes are around 10 to 15
minutes each obviously some are shorter
some are longer venture of course um
have you come close to
doing any have you discussed doing any
that were like 30 minutes have you
discussed doing like a feature of love
death and robots we talk about it
amongst ourselves i think one of the
challenges in this is to maintain
anthology feel and also allow each
studio to be able to handle a number of
minutes that could allow it to be super
high quality in a boutique studio that
may not usually have the personnel to do
like something bigger
yeah i i mean we're we're open to it but
we're very committed to the short form
at the moment but it should be an
incubator and it'd be nice to do longer
longer things for sure i i it it becomes
a different set of challenges the the
really short ones are particularly
difficult
to tell something satisfying in a five
minute and like all through the house
is a perfect example of that feels
just right for what it is um but some
stories demand more
that's why there's short stories and
novellas and novels have any not been
made due to cost like even if it was
going to be 15 minutes
just the challenge i don't know the
challenges of making it just you know
what i mean
there was one episode that we didn't
make simply because of the sheer number
of
creatures
oh oh yes yes
yes so that one would have been amazing
we had a director that wanted to do it
so badly
they wanted it so bad but we looked at
it and thought
dinosaurs are expensive
lots of dinosaurs are very expensive
all different dinosaurs you can't listen
we regularly go through
a compression
process um you know and and you can i
i've been doing this so long now that as
when i work on the scripts i'm trying to
get rid of the really obvious budget
plus
elements
um or things that are going to kill
animators unlike alberto who enjoys
making life difficult for himself and
his crew
let's do cloth in water with hair
and cards and blood lots of blood yeah
and lots of coins
in trees
um yeah uh that episode uh i don't know
how he did it we could spend the 20
minutes just talking about that um have
you guys actually i know that one of the
things about love and death and robots
that's great is your champion
championing i don't know what that word
is uh you know short stories and
novellas in new worlds that people have
not seen however i love the storytelling
and i'm curious if you guys have ever
discussed like using ip
of um like ip that exists and trying to
tell a love death and robot story with
that ip
i i had never thought of that until this
brilliant interviewer
suggested it to me during a phone call
and i thought genuinely that's a genius
[ __ ] idea
politically and creatively um i thought
that was a great idea i do think that
there i mean it is a challenge that we
pick 18 stories that
very few people have read or heard of
even though some are by
enormously famous authors and present
them to the world um
you can't deny that it would be helpful
that if some of these were were very
well known
um brands in and of themselves so it's
an interesting story but but the there i
do feel like you lose a little bit of
freedom because you're kind of
you know you're restrained by what's
been done before
uh and and
being true to the brand as as
blur works in video games all the time
and
and uh
you have to work you have to draw within
the lines um
which is cool you know
i mean there's also the added advantage
of the fan base with vip but you know
anyway um jen uh david told me that you
helped him do the storyboards on his
episode um and he said he would talk to
you like monday wednesday and friday for
like an hour or maybe he said it's once
a week for an hour uh but he said he was
very grateful so what is it like doing
storyboards for david fincher it was
crazy it was awesome i mean i love doing
star wars i always started board on my
own stuff i helped a lot of the director
of storyboard on the show because i
don't come out of their budget i'm like
a free storyboard artist do you want
help story i'll do story for you she did
it time
well it's you know i'm great but in the
case of david fincher i think that
he comes from live action even though
he's a huge supporter of animation the
process of it might have been a little
bit more to deal with and we wanted to
make sure he didn't have to deal with as
much as he had to
um storyboarding with him is like going
through film school because you are
learning about lenses and cameras in a
way that's very much live action based
and also trying to funnel it into
something that's animatable
so he would just on the zoom call be
talking through shots and i would
literally storyboard as fast as he was
talking trying to get these little stick
figures done as quickly as possible and
then i would send it to him like a
couple hours later and then he would
send me notes and send it back to him
we would do that back and forth and we
did that for pretty much an entire short
except for a couple of the conversation
spots because then you could plot that
out in the room jen jen has this skill
that i think is very necessary for the
show
um i have it to a lesser degree but i
i'm continually a work in progress where
you can put yourself in the position of
i'm just going to help this person do
the best
version of of their vision right so
you're not there like a director is
usually supposed to be the one going
that go that way and do that and make it
red um but in in a lot of the the a lot
of this job is helping other people
achieve their vision and it's a
particular mindset that you can um sort
of go into
uh i i was second unit for days
on some of the bad traveling stuff um
because i could be helpful about mocap
or things like that jen did storyboards
and you just kind of put your ego and
what you would do to to one side and and
try and use your skills in
in the
in the direction that they want to go uh
even if it's not the one that you want
to go and it's really rewarding you know
working with alberto is particularly
that way where there's so many decisions
that i go [ __ ] i would never do that and
then you look at it and you go but it's
[ __ ] cool
and and that is what this show is about
in a lot of ways i'm curious tim what is
it like to try to keep fincher on budget
and letting go of shots when he is a
perfectionist
you know everybody thinks that he's got
this fearsome reputation and it is
deserved but uh he's never been anything
but reasonable
with me in that regard for sure um at
the end of dragon tattoo we did the
title which was the first time we really
worked together
he called me and said hey i'm in the
neighborhood i'm going to drop by at the
end of the process and i
kept waiting the whole time for the shoe
to drop right the other shoe to drop the
the
david fincher that you hear stories
about to come out and i'm like
why are you coming by what's wrong is
there something that
he's like dude i'm just i'm just coming
by because i'm in the neighborhood and i
and i want to applaud because i think it
looks great
um
and and that's the way he's always been
he's a good collaborator good with the
actors go to the artist good with
all of us
is there a studio um that you
would love to work with that maybe
you've asked and thus far they said no
or
because like for me i'm just wondering
like what do i need to do to get studio
ghibli to do something with you guys in
this world
oh there are a couple i can't say
because it didn't happen but there are a
couple studios and people that we wish
we could have worked on
that's not an episode with but it's just
a matter of it's just it doesn't work
out sometimes but perhaps sometime in
the future it will
i will say that i'm obscurely happy that
we have trouble finding great 2d
animation companies to to work on the
show
if you would thought about this a few
years back you would you would say that
oh well eventually 3d is going to take
over everything but there's been a real
renaissance
of 2d animation
and i think netflix is responsible for a
lot of that they have
literally armies of 2d animators around
the world producing great work
and um there's certainly a dearth
of uh
of talent out there when we go looking
for it yeah because everyone's working
it's a great reason everybody's working
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of shows and movies
uh you guys know that for fans of the
series what's something that you want to
tell them about it that perhaps like
they don't know or like you want to
shine a light on a certain aspect do you
know what i mean like
talking about something that doesn't get
championed or you know an unsung hero i
think um you you speak to us
we're in a lot of these interviews but i
think the thing that people don't
necessarily know is that
there is an a hub of people
here at blur that basically deal with
all the different studios and they've
carried through all three seasons and it
is truly a passion project for all and
so
you know like victoria howard who's
sitting right there off camera because
she's
amazing and we couldn't do the show
without her
and
she makes it all possible i mean if you
if you can't get stuff done there's
never been a moment where i went to
victoria said i really want this and she
said yeah well your [ __ ] out a lot
she makes it happen and if you don't
have a producer like that if you don't
have a production team that's willing to
go that extra mile and ours do because
they love this show they really love
this show
then you know you're just a dude in a
room talking to yourself right
not making art uh i completely
understand that listen i just want to
thank you for and thank everyone for
everyone's hard work and uh thank you
for talking with me and i hope it's a
huge hit
you